on visite les îles pour se ressourcer se
dépayser et profiter d'un cadre
idyllique
mais chaque jour c'est aussi près d'une
demi douzaine de spectacles qui sont à
la fiche des vedettes qui ne se font pas
prier pour venir se produire dans ce
paysage de carte postale moi je veux je
peux péter une petite crise de prince r
si géniaux posez-les sur une tournée
puis plus qu'une fois si possible des
stars du continent qui côtoie dvd
desiles comme tenter ma du là et bien là
qu'est ce que tu fais comme tu fuck jeu
vendu plus de cent mille billets pour
son spectacle qu'elle présente depuis 20
ans jfr prête la carte dédiée à la
manière d'un d'une madelinienne de
madelinots pour les faire découvrir ce
qu'on est nous les gens les
particularités des villages les accents
que ce soit pour tourner des films
ça
des émissions télé ou des vidéoclips les
élus ont la cote c'est énorme mais on a
des demandes que je me demande si ch
pour épater d'accepter leur dise c'est
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de demandes
et puis ça vraiment fait un gros boum un
bouillonnement qu'on constate également
au populaire bar spectacle les pas
perdus on voyait quand même avant la
pandémie qu'on était pour avoir des
problèmes de
2,2 staff d'employés c'est toujours des
records on va dire c'est même un peu des
records c'est encore une grosse soirée
plus grands soirs et plus de gros soirée
dans l'année
et malgré l'abondance de l'offre le
public est au rendez vous et les
artistes en redemande tu arrives ici il
ya un esprit musical
c'est clair les gens mangent la musique
une offre culturelle foisonnante qui
fait plaisir aux madelinots la fureur
ces camps et offrent trop grande et qui
sait plus quoi choisir se découvre
poteau trouve au poteau mais aussi un
raz-de-marée de touristes qui entraînent
dans leur sillage sur lot d'irritants ou
pas oublier que quand même une
collective du monde qui vit à l'année
passée pour on n'est pas reluisant des
craintes dont sont bien conscients les
acteurs économiques locaux qui scrute
l'horizon et ça fait plusieurs années
j'irai depuis 2014 2015 environ que le
nombre de visiteurs est plafonnée on
estime en fait que tourner au maximum il
est à peu près un visiteur un touriste
par résident à madelinots en même temps
sur les halles de la madeleine
par contre la saison touristique
s'allonge et ses vagues de touristes sur
des îles qui ne compte que douze mille
habitants est un réel défi dans un
contexte de pénurie de main d'oeuvre et
de logement
tout le monde vous le dira aux îles il y
à des musiciens dans chaque famille
c'est ce qui a plu aux musiciens et
copropriétaire du vent du large qui a
mis le cap sur les îles il ya près de
dix ans on était très très bien écrit
mais je dois dire que ça a aidé d'avoir
un violon dans les mecs ça c'est ça a
été un passeport dès notre arrivée
maison c'est cette culture forte qui
également incité le champ seigner claude
cornier à revenir accoster sur son île
il ya eu je tai lang deux soirs par
semaine il présente une boîte à chansons
où il partage la scène avec des
musiciens invités du monde qui nous ont
précédés
aujourd'hui au porte le flambeau et ceux
qui surviennent c'est cette atteint brut
c'est incroyable les jeunes sont
talentueux la culture des îles la
musique des ailes pourpres est disparate
le défi de la madeleine est maintenant
de naviguer entre les ambitions
touristiques et la volonté de conserver
un milieu de vie agréable pour les
madelinots qui habitent à l'année ici
des biens alexandre chartier
radio-canada havre-aubert rosé de la
madeleine